well facebook is banning president trump
from posting on its platforms at least
until joe biden's inauguration ceo mark
zuckerberg said in a statement it was
clear donald trump intended to use his
remaining time in office
to undermine the peaceful transition of
power he wrote this
we believe the risks of allowing the
president to continue to use our service
during this period
are simply too great therefore we're
extending the block we have placed on
his facebook and instagram accounts
indefinitely
and for at least the next two weeks
until the peaceful transition of power
is complete alan fisher is standing by
at the white house for reaction but
first we'll bring in paddy culhane
to set the scene for us uh patty in
capitol hill
it's a very different scene than around
this time yesterday when the police
rushed in and said
there's a suspicious package all the
media needs to get out
and we went out and then we saw the mob
of people just descending
from where they had been protesting
surrounding the capitol
it's a much more secure scene today
national guard troops have been seen on
the streets now
they're putting up a what they call a
seven foot unscalable fence
but there are a lot of questions about
just how prepared police were
how they behaved towards those
protesters the chief of the capitol hill
police put out a statement
praising what he called that his
officers responded valiantly
but there are real questions about why
they didn't have more people why they
didn't have better security
and people are now starting to go
through their offices on capitol hill
one congressman said that uh they stole
a laptop
they're just trying to clean up the
damage figure out the extent of it
find those responsible because a lot of
the outrages about how those protesters
were treated
they weren't necessarily arrested their
selfies are they were taken
there's pictures on social media of what
appears to be a police officer taking
selfies
with some of the protesters another
video on social media
shows what appears to be capital police
moving the barricades and letting people
in
so there's some real questions because
of this unprecedented attack
on the nation's capital let's take a
look at how it all unfolded